how many ties mr. dighby rolled so the
probability of rolling at least one six
is greater than 95% so another way of
saying that is how many times must you
roll such that your chairs are going to
95% that's the same okay how do we
phrase this now pause for a moment
before you put pen to paper i want you
to look very carefully at a wedding of
the question it says the probability of
rolling at least one six at least one
six okay
now that means I could one roll one six
or two sixes or three sixes or four
sixes or 18 one of those right I can
work out what this probabilities off and
then I could add them all up that's one
way we're putting this question okay
there are at least three problems with
Dorien that way number one I don't know
how many times I have to add it up
that's the whole part of the question
guys how many times you get her all I
don't know how many times you've roll
okay that's the first issue the second
issue is this is just gonna take me a
very long time no matter how many like
it could be five or it could be fifty
they're all going to be terrible right
so therefore I don't want to have to
deal with the sixes right
what are we much better is to look at
the question and say there's only one
way to not have any sixes so the one way
to have not instances right it's to roll
all non sixes does that make sense
so now I'm ready to start writing the
probability sorry the probability of
getting a six sorry a six is 1/6 right
the probability of not rolling a six is
five six right okay
so therefore really the probability of
having no success at all is just the
compliment of rolling if you like once
it's does that make sense
so here's the way I'm going to phrase
this if the probability of rate of
rolling all the sixes and they're going
to extend this or a single event to
multiple minutes the problem very
audiences is 1 6 ^ however many times
you're wrong
okay then the probability of Nowruz
ceases must be the complement of that it
must be the complement does that makes
it so this is how am I gonna write this
one - what so this this one is really
one take away this see that is this one
take away what
no sixes none what's about six do you
see why think about it think about it
I want the compliment right so the only
way to avoid the sixes is to roll
everything down six right so this is
rolling an on six and then another non
six and then another on six n times does
that make sense yeah you with me I'm
sorry you're right
I'm in this this is the actual question
at least one six so this is the
probability of rolling those sixes and
this is actually what the question is
saying right at least one six does that
make sense okay love it that's fine
now what I want is for this number one
takeaway I want this to be what greater
than 95% right greater than 95% is it
inclusive I don't think so as it turns
out doesn't really matter so now this is
actually very simple this is really not
even about like by the granule this is
just about exhibit do you see that
because what you're solving for is the
power so I'm going to I guess I'll
subtract one from both sides this is -
this is 0.95 right so if I subtract one
that has a look I'll divide both sides
through space what would you like me to
do now be careful inequalities
I think I take logs on both sides take
logs of both sides okay because the log
of a smaller number will still be
smaller than the log of a big enough so
if I take logs of both sides I'm not
gonna skip anything here with my log
floors
okay so I've just taken logs of both
sides everything's all good bring this
guy out the front because that's my new
servant how a lot yeah what would you do
now
I should divide through by hips but be
careful right we know that log base E of
E is 1 right and if you bigger numbers
in here this will get bigger right ah
but this this is actually to get smaller
than 1 right that's right we know that
log 1 is 0 and this is less than 1 right
and of course if you want you getting a
bit confused at signs and directions
it's just go it up and I think you'll
get negative 0.2 or something like that
okay so I'm going to divide cube up
because it's negative I have to change
the sign again call you by the way of
course it has to change the direction
think about it think they think we want
it to be greater than 95% right so you
need to roll more and more times and
should be getting bigger not smaller
right so that's why it's 10 is greater
than okay can someone give me the
decimal to this I can't roll it a
fraction or decimal number of times so
I'm just gonna have to roll it the whole
lumbar role at least 17 times okay does
this make sense you see how I approached
it so you've got to sort of pieces here
which are a bit sneaky number one you
have to recognize it as a compliment
there's not really any nice efficient
way to do this otherwise I mean it's
still time-consuming
even the efficient way and secondly just
be careful with your logs there's lots
of traffic
and students gets at this point they'll
say it is less than sixteen point four
they weren't Nerdist but that doesn't
make sense you can't have less and get
more and more likely right you need more
roles not fewer roles and so students
like it's a sixteen and they'll
surrender mark